[Music]
you're incredible to understand I'm
serious we did it without you spend the
next big strong you on this because I'm
feeling we know just keep your head now
[Music]
so I told you about my brother yeah
something happened I don't know exactly
what you shouldn't arrest is being held
at Rikers Island oh my god that's awful
you just got to get him out of there
before something bad happens if you get
killed in there
and another 10 grant you get another 10
grand your butt will get out the truth
[Music]
I think something very important was
happening and it's deeply connected to
my purpose every day I think about on
twisting and untangling these strings
I'm in to lead a Pure Life
look ahead and clear sky ain't gonna get
there
it's a nice dream
it's a nice dream
[Music]
your other Explorer give me a hint
don't be afraid your dream to be in a
forest I wish to find a lost city what
you seek is far greater than you ever
imagined your soul will never be quiet
until you find this race it is your
destiny
there's a major expiration of us
terrible disease murderous savages the
journey may well mean your life don't go
you'll not know you when you return I
know this is a sacrifice for all of us
they won't be worth it a man's reach
should exceed his grasp
I am proposing it Amazonia contain a
hidden civilization if we may find a
city where one was considered impossible
to exist it's may well write a whole new
chapter in human history are you
insisting that these savages there are
inputs their civilization may well be
data
I call it set the ultimate piece of the
human puzzle I strongly advise you to
abort the mission it's become far too
dangerous
there is no turning I stay here and
struck them to provide for the children
while you wonder the jungle you don't
care about us you don't even care about
them
nobody care about her lost city
this search for said I can no longer
bear the cost
you've come to doubt its existence no
not only doubt had said to provide all
the artists you seek from
[Music]
[Music]
all I have for you is a word
[Music]
lieutenant it'll open the right doors
some of the wrong ones too
use it carefully to do what I do I need
some idea of the threat we face as I
understand it we're trying to prevent
World War 3 I'm not saying I'm again
[Music]
something was I can't do you have an
interest Russian national likes me man
here they won enough you can communicate
with the future
tap travel no inversion a mitten in full
retreat yeah shooting the bullet you
know catching it
what I've seen too much my trying keeper
community transcends national interests
this is about survival
seems whoa
hold up fine with a tight we're gonna
say nuts
this is where our blue sky
how would you like to die oh you chose
the wrong profession
[Music]
that's in here
has it happened yet
there are people in the future who need
us
I need tenant
we need to save them here and now
this reversing the flow of time wasn't
us being here now it never happened you
want to crash a plane but not from the
air no such massive well having a plane
that part is a little dramatic
show me my car
any special reason we're in the car
through the office
what makes you think we're in the car
set up the office what do you do exactly
I think you acquire information and turn
it into something stupendous and awful
it's the glow of cyber capital so
radiant seductive do you ever get the
feeling that you don't know what's going
on
[Music]
situation isn't stable I know I'm losing
money by the ton hundreds of millions
there is someone who's prepared to kill
you my personal fortune is in ruins and
there's been a credible threat on my
life makes me feel free in a way I've
never known free to do what people eat
and sleep in the shadow of what we do
this is a protest against the future the
urge to destroy it's a creative energy
interesting tavini remember somebody
wants a gal I'm looking for more it's
done me it's my DNA
show me something I don't know
I thought you were some kind of big to
destroy people in the blink of an eye
they're dangerous person
you're caught waking life is
self-contradiction we still want what we
want
[Music]
everything in our lives has brought us
to this moment
[Music]
she's mine
[Music]
[Music]
we were scum trash refuse that didn't
fit into the system
until someone had the bright idea that
recycling us serve science the arts are
not in our favor but when my work is
accomplished when perfection isn't she
in - then what fly away I know I look
like a wish you're foxy and you know it
this mission can't turn our shame to
some type of glory I can't do this
flying around them the sensation moving
backwards even though I'm moving forward
getting further from what's getting
nearer
[Applause]
[Music]
there's nothing to fear break the laws
of nature now pay for it
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the spectacular father
[Applause]
excuse me sir can we help you
you know circuses thank you 31 was the
Benzini brothers that's the most famous
circus disaster of all time are you
telling me that you were there right in
the middle of it I don't know I picked
that circus something told me that
circus picked me
[Music]
the world's run on tricks everyone plays
beautiful woman deserve a beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'd like to make an announcement
Hogwarts castle will not only be your
home this year but home to some very
special guests as well these cracks will
draw the proud sons of drum sprang and
now lovely ladies of God battements
[Music]
I was just wondering if maybe he wanted
to go to the ball with me mr. Weasley is
your right hand on my waist
[Music]
I'm only green Jeff with Victor Krum
your fan isin with the enemy he enemy
Hogwarts has been chosen to host a
legendary event the tray wizard
tournament and now can't get to exit
crap
[Music]
how did you do I didn't put my name in
that car I don't want eternal glory it's
not a murder the killing curse only one
person is known to have survived at
their sitting in this room people died
in this tournament
the Devils are inside the walls
[Music]
it's always coming closer
arise
is it for the vault
[Music]
[Music]
everything's going to change as a day
[Music]
[Music]